you look amazing
you what you look incredible I'm just in
my pyjamas visit you know you look
incredible you look happy thank you
really happy there's so much to
celebrate or so much so much so much
happiness life is beautiful hurry I'm so
proud of you
let's just throw it back to Sunday it
was your night thank you so much but
congratulations on the award you
performed without Canadian boy yes right
he taught me some of the words like an
idiot you know okay the one hand they
sign I know this nation you're telling
me not true never Canadian nose we went
to see the Raptor really made him play
the Canadian national anthem so I was
like I want to learn it cuz I want to
stand up and do it oh my gosh you need
to you have to come and do it at a
rappers game I put it out there in the
world in energy I'd like to think I'm an
honorary anymore I don't think you're an
honorary Canadian honorary Canadian you
are but you know the biggest moment for
me was when you perform living proof
thank you it was a moment thank you have
you absorbed everything that happened on
Sunday it's a lot it's a lot how do you
feel about it honestly I to be
completely honest with you I have not
had the chance to watch the performance
oh okay
I have not cuz I've been like literally
working non-stop till right now yeah so
I haven't been able to but I have a day
off tomorrow so I'll watch the
performance in like really like take it
in because I haven't been able to yet
but it was really amazing it was if it
felt amazing it was really fun and you
kind of think Toronto or a you think
Sean's mom I mean it's your honor
yes he took me just like I have all the
neighbors cheering for me yeah and the
greatest part was you performing with
your friend Taylor Swift that was a
statement it was a movement you and
Halsey there and then sing Selena in the
audience yeah what does it mean for you
to support her when she's fighting the
good fight for all the artists out there
yeah I mean I think that she's just
she's such an inspiring woman and she
just she really just stands up for what
she believes in and I think that she is
like not even consciously is is such a
mentor to me because just kind of seeing
the way she acts and the way she handles
things and the passion that she has is
super inspiring to me and also to be
honest with you like just has a Taylor
Swift trend cuz I grew up being the
biggest Taylor Swift fan I was like I
was just bummed that I couldn't be in
the front row glistening to her sing her
old songs because I was like if she
sings enchanted I was it but I know her
entire discography so you know getting
to like hear her sing like love story
backstage and have my mic in my hand and
know that I was gonna go sing with her
I think Halsey felt the same way because
she is just literally the soundtrack to
our lives you know like every one of my
friends it's like that's what we'll
listen to when we go home and we're like
having wine and like crying about boys
somebody's crying about boys what do we
do we put on like Taylor Swift's entire
decided be so you know being able to
sing with her it was really like a
surreal moment for me I've really got
the chance to kind of like I reminded
myself like really take that in because
13-year old you would be like what and
you're not surreal is your new album
that's coming out the most anticipated
album romance December 6 you're putting
it out in the world and these this seems
like it's very personal to you is it a
reflection of what's been going on for
you for the because last two years right
yeah yeah oh my god yeah I mean these
songs are basically they're my life and
just every crazy experience that I've
had I mean not every single one cuz I
actually wrote 80 songs for this album
no way yeah how did you pick the ones
you want it for the album I think you
just know because you scroll yeah and
you scroll past the ones you don't want
to listen to and you click on the ones
you do want to listen to so it just kind
of narrow
down to like 13 songs really yeah but
these songs are like I think I just
really I was I just lived life for the
first time I actually have a line about
that I'm one of the songs I wrote a
lyric that was like I was not living I
was just writing about it and it felt
like that was kind of my first album
like it was like I was writing about
these emotions that I wanted to feel and
I think that in this album it was like
things were happening to me and I was
writing about them and and I just a lot
of happen
I'm nervous about putting it out there
in the world because I know you one last
time we talked or when you talk to et
condos and you had a lot of anxiety
about your first album are you worried
about this one there's a half and a half
like I feel like there's the half of me
that's like is of course I'm nervous
because it's my sophomore album and I've
you know worked almost a year on it and
it's my baby and these songs are also
important to me and then there's the
other half that's like I kind of just
want to put stuff out and I look at it
as more of kind of like a diary and I'm
just like okay I finished that chapter
put it out and then I keep on writing my
book you know what I mean it's your
journey yeah it's your journey and I
love the way you didn't detailed how you
wanted this album to sound you said you
want to sound like how it following your
love feels like yeah which is so
interesting just putting those words out
that way yeah how would you describe
falling in love in a few words hmm
consuming mm-hmm um magical I was gonna
say sweaty palms but that's a good
sweaty palms is basically all three of
those except romantical nineties ready
palms a magical and the name romance is
so interesting I've been married 16
years I still check out my husband we're
missing the romance part so what is the
perfect or what is the most romantic
thing for you hmm I think the most
romantic thing for me is I think you
just feel it in there when like somebody
like looks you in the eyes and tells you
something that they really mean or you
know touches you or kisses you in a way
that you really feel it and I think that
there's you can just feel the emotion
behind it you know what I mean when
somebody it's like really difficult to
explain it's like not really a
thought-out gesture it's just more of a
feeling that somebody transmits you when
you feel like oh wow like there is
really something here you know and
everyone's gonna get to feel about
romance because you're going on a North
American tour what does it feel like for
you to be able to give that to your fans
oh my god I'm so excited I'm so excited
because I love making albums like I
haven't released an album in like a year
and a half and I haven't like just put
out songs and singles because to me
putting out an album means what is the
world like what is the visuals like what
is what are the colors what is the story
that you're going to tell in the
performance like in a concert like to me
an album is like the soundtrack to the
concert and like everything like all of
the visuals and like the kind of
Renaissance ethereal like heaven sort of
visuals like the world that we've
constructed for romance like that to me
is the tour and I just really wanted
this album to be just like a form of
just like escapism to people like escape
into this beautiful like world of
emotion and and falling in love and the
good and the bad in that bringing the
happiness back to your fans yeah yeah
you know this morning I tweeted out that
was gonna be chatting with you your fans
are crazy they love you and I know you
were off social media for a while and
now you're back and you were so open
with them you talk about everything
that's happening in your life is it a is
it a nice outlet for you to be able to
do that yeah I mean I think it feels
really good for me when I'm able to with
like when I feel like I'm really being
myself on social media where you know
like when I do questions and answer and
answer things and they asked me for
advice or they tell me things that are
going on in their lives like I just like
feeling like I can help them or be there
for them or just connect with them in
any way because I think my fans and I
have this relationship where I don't
think they look at me as like this kind
of like celebrity Idol person like
I think that to them I'm like their
friend that they're rooting for you know
what I mean yeah I got deal that room
from from my fans yeah and so I think
that we have a really good relationship
where you know like on days where I'm
like struggling with anxiety like I'm
like open about that and so when they
tell me I'm like oh I've been doing this
meditation I've been doing this and so
it's just like a very I don't know I
think we just give to each other a lot
in more ways than just the music like I
think there's like a real kind of
friendship it's cool and Zillah or come
you know communal I tzer's comida lasers
I totally got that wrong we're trying to
figure out how to do that it's okay I've
actually gotten it wrong for the past
okay two years I think I got it I they
used to say canalize errs catalyzers
that can work too but that's wrong oh
but it sounds like a camel sounds like
they're supporting a camel right they do
not god no no no but they support your
amazing song senorita I mean
congratulations on the Grammy nomination
kikou thank you you know but this is you
know what's so special about this that
you're sharing with someone that you
absolutely love and admire that's extra
special isn't it oh my god it's so
special I mean I remember like it's so
crazy for me to think about when Shawn
and I met like five years ago we were
like 16 I don't hear no were like 16 17
years old you know we were just kids and
for us to be like nominated for a Grammy
now together and like all the memories
that this song has and all the memories
that we have together like in our
friendship is really really it's really
amazing to be able to share that with
somebody that there's a lot to you and
that song doesn't stop everyone loves
that it keeps going and going and going
and go away yeah and that video makes it
keep going so hard was it functioning
that it was I'm not sure fun was no of
course it was fun it was like so
nerve-wracking because it's like we were
just friends so we were like oh my god
we have to kiss each other like it was
like it was we had to have tequila shots
did you why no tequila shots the
holidays are coming up yeah what do you
want from Santa nuts keyless shots I
don't want no hangovers
it's Christmas anything you want this
year um what do I want this here I
really would just love to have a movie
marathon oh yeah which is your favorite
movie movies that I just haven't watched
like all classic classic movies like I
haven't seen like Goodfellas Oh haven't
seen everybody everybody what what what
I haven't seen like big by Tom Hanks a
lot like yeah there's a lot of I I'm
coming with you come to my house okay
great okay we will do this together I'll
be there because I'm honorary can come
to my house I'll give you my phone
number after we'll hang out and watch
all those move grades I did this at the
game two six six
now if Santa were to pick are you on the
naughty list or on the nice list
I think I'm nice nice I wish I could be
Rihanna and say I'm naughty but I'm
doing I love it they kept asking about
Cinderella yes are you doing the live
adaptation for it so the questions I got
was are you gonna make new music for it
yes who do you want to play Prince
Charming can't say and the last one was
uh who's your fairy godmother well in
case you can't know in life yeah my
fairy godmother is 1 billion percent my
mom your mom oh my god yeah she's better
than fairy yeah how does she feel about
all this she's I mean I don't know she
just said I think it sad I mean I think
she's just really really proud of me but
I I think that she just I think parents
like she's not looking at this from a
superficial way I think she's just like
seeing the person that I am and and how
I handled things is just a human being
but of course she feels super proud
proud of me yeah but yeah and we're
proud of you you meet the list of Time
Magazine's top next 100 most influential
yeah you are creating a pathway with
Latino music and that's a big deal thank
you what did it mean for you to be part
of that list oh my god it's so cool I
mean you saying that now I was like what
that's me that's crazy
um I think it's really amazing and it
just
makes me more motivated to just use my
platform to help my fans help help
people and like whatever way I can
whether that's through music or just
kind of sharing like what it's like to
just be human because I think that's
what helps people most of all sometimes
yeah you know it's just being open just
being open
you're my kindred spirit because I
understand that you like pineapples on
your pizza yeah
how does nobody get I don't understand
why does everybody make us feel bad it's
so good it's so good and people make us
feel so bad I have to hide it if I hate
I know I it's true I think I talked to
the pizza with pineapple because my
husband doesn't like to pineapple yeah
yeah don't make us feel bad and in Italy
forget about it you can't do it can't
say that no you can't I've almost said
it in restaurants but I know I'll get
killed yeah I was gonna bring you
Nando's today but I did it I don't know
any Toronto food yet eats a pizza yeah
Pizza Pizza yes when will you be back in
Toronto maybe a white Christmas um not
for Christmas but I'll be there in the
end of the year before the end of the
year the tour right yeah yeah what has
all this meant to you have you had a
chance to sit back and kind of reflect
everything that's happened for you hmm I
don't know like I I think that I I just
I reflect a lot I guess on just what my
life is like but I think that my career
and the music is just one part of it you
know what I mean so I don't know I I
think that there are moments like where
it really sinks in like when you just
said the time thing to me now I was like
wow this is really cool that I get to do
this er there are times where I don't
know I'll be performing and I'll be like
oh my god this is like what I've wanted
to do since I was a little girl and it's
still what I want to do and I feel
really lucky that I get to do it for a
living because I think that music to me
is like my it's it's everything to me
like I don't know who I would be without
that outlet like it like heals me and
and saves me like over and over and over
again and makes me connect to myself
over and over and over again and I think
that it's actually important to remind
yourself that because I think that a lot
of artists that I know like a lot of
friends that I have because we feel a
lot of pressure because the pressure is
real and there's a lot of people
watching you can get
you know like for example before award
show performances you can get like
really really nervous to the point where
it's like you feel like too nervous to
be able to enjoy it and then you have to
just remind yourself like I did this in
my room because it was my favorite thing
to do so what is the difference in
between then and now besides few more
people watching you know what I mean but
I think I reflect on on that a lot like
the fact that this is really really for
me like no matter what happens like I
need to do this for myself to be happy
my favorite song to sing my favorite
song to saying that's such a good
question um favorite song to sing I mean
this is so random but I really love
defying gravity from wicked does that go
I think I'll try defying gravity
my boss is completely Canadian national
anthem is my very own surface try a try
Cassie Oh Canada
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you